[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who looks like this at the
start of a boys night out
and this by the end of it the finale for
falcon and the winter soldier is almost
here
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down our predictions
theories
and what we think will be happening it's
not like we get any of these right
anyway but full spoiler alert for
everything up to the ending of episode 5
so if you haven't checked that out then
check out now if you enjoy the video
then please smash the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our predictions
okay so a big question hanging over the
series
is who is the power broker all signs
seem to be pointing towards sharon
carter
and because of this i think it's way too
obvious to actually be her
tv shows are pretty much built on the
idea of red herrings
and she is very much this shows there's
pretty much
no suspects beyond her that could be the
power broker and thus i think they've
set it up
in order to try and trick us but it
won't bloody work
it won't work now this is because she's
someone who allowed sam bucky and zemo
to go and interrogate nagel
which if he's the power broker's golden
goose
doesn't make sense she also went into a
fight which i don't think that the
villain would do
and according to zemo the antagonist was
around before he got sent to prison
which is when she was operating as agent
13. so no
it won't bloody work now in the last
episode we watched as she rehired batroc
to help out the flag smashers
and he stated he wanted to kill the
falcon however he's called captain
america now so got you on the
technicality there
although this order seems to be coming
from sharon it may
either be one of his own personal
vendettas or it could just be a bluff
in order to get them to trust him i
actually think that sharon will help
stop the flag smashes in the show
and that she will get her pardon because
of this in a recent tv spot we did see
her walking through a car park with a
red flashing light behind her
and this looked very similar to the one
at the grc headquarters in episode 5.
therefore i think that she will be at
the location working against them to win
favor with the us
so she can return once more but it won't
blo sorry
it might work it probably will work now
sam might be able to pull a few strings
but it's not like anyone has helped
since she's been away
so i think at this point she's taking
things into her own hands
and handling her business like a boss
however i do think that currently
she is working for the power broker
sharon is very well connected at this
point
and operating in mad report seems to
have put her in a good place to be his
or hers accomplice is hers i don't know
i'm terrible with grammar now as for the
power brokers themselves
i think that it will likely be revealed
as curtis jackson
and or dr carl maylis the pair of which
form power broker incorporated in the
source material
this dealt with selling superpowers and
it lines up a lot with the experiments
that were carried out on the flag
smashers
however as they haven't been in the show
yet we can't say for definite that it is
these characters
if i had to theorize based off the
people that we've already had in the
series so far
i would actually say that val definitely
fits the bill
in the source material valentina allegra
de la fontaine was a villain that too
worked in madrapue
this was when she was helping to head up
a group known as the femme force
which sharon carter also just happened
to be a member of
from isaiah's story we know that the
super soldier serum can also be
extracted from someone's blood
and through this method it is possible
to replicate it
thus her having a close eye on john
walker makes a lot of sense
as he's one of the only people left
alive who still carries the formula in
his blood
i think this could be why she recruited
him as the power broker of course wants
to see her more than anything else
and thus her taking him under her wing
is a great way to do it
we know that val is going to be popping
up in the mcu a lot more
and she's currently slated to return in
black widow therefore
she could definitely be this high
profile character the power broker
or maybe not you know now they might be
doing their own thing with her
which i probably think is more likely
but out of everyone we've met so far on
the show
i think that she is currently the number
one contender
now i would love to see her go and get
zemo from the raft
and have her recruit him we saw in his
cell in episode 3 that he kept a god's
card in his machiavelli book
and i think it would be great to see him
in the raft then opening up said book
and discovering val's blank card this
was such a cool thing that she did with
walker
and for him to find one in his book were
teased at either the thunderbolts or
dark avengers being set up
now as for the plot line itself i'm
guessing that we're going to be picking
up immediately after the ending of
episode 5
and that we will watch as our heroes
converge on the grc
to stop the flag smashes though we don't
know what was in sam's case
we know it's from wakanda is it wakanda
anyway we know it's from wakanda and i
hope that it's his white captain america
suit along with some vibranium wings
i'd also love to see wacky in taurus
having fixed up the broken ones
and then becoming the falcon himself
much like how he was in the source
material i wanted john walker
and the last time we saw the character
he was having his iron man-esque moment
in which he was putting together his own
shield if you thought he looked like a
cosplay cap at the end of episode one
then i can't wait to see what he looks
like after a bit of diy
in the trailers we saw him handing out
some vigilante justice
courtesy of uncle sam's most decorated
douchebag
and it looks like he's gonna go to the
flag smashes himself in order to try and
stop them and win back favor
there's been a lot of leaks of him
kicking the crap out of them
and this scene is very reminiscent of
sam wilson captain america
when he fought sam in the street now
this was done when the character got the
mantle of captain america
and walker was hired to publicly
embarrass him i think it could be
similar here but i
actually have faith that walker is going
to do the right thing and side with sam
in winter soldier he ran a therapy group
for vets and i think that he could very
much
talk walker down from doing something
stupid like
releasing a white boy summer video you
idiot chet hanks that was
we didn't want you to do that you [ __ ]
it was just a joke
now the trailers also seem to show what
looked like it could have been a funeral
scene
i believe this might actually be walkers
and potentially he will
die during the fight now when i say die
i actually think that it will be
revealed later on that
like steve after the first avenger he's
in some sort of deep sleep somewhere and
is actually still alive
in the comics walker was apparently
killed and then he came back as a us
agent so i think something similar might
happen here
if this funeral scene does happen it
could also be where steve re-emerges to
publicly make sam captain america
though i know that is definitely going
to be a long shot now as for bucky i
think he's going to go to mr nakajima in
the closing scenes
and he will admit what he did to his son
this is something that was set up in
episode 1 but it seems to have been
forgotten about
however in episode 5 sam clearly showed
him that if he wants to forgive himself
he has to get the forgiveness of others
too thus i think he will go to mr
nakajima
and this will be the culmination of his
orc i know a lot of people think that
bucky is gonna die
but i personally can't see it and i
think that things will remain
relatively the same as they were at the
end of end game
the sam will still be captain america
bucky will be fine
and the pair will be ready to move out
of steve's shadow and into
the light aka captain america
and the white wolf season confirmed
betting my entire channel on that
well actually it was beyond epic who
told me that so bet his channel on it
the idiot now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you comment
below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
during the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts and theories the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the shanxi trailer
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom
and it's definitely worth checking out
if you if you have any questions about
that movie
and without the way thank you for
sending through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time take care peace
but it won't bloody work
it won't work